explosive testimony on Capitol Hill over
government censorship Twitter files
journalists Matt taibi and Michael
shellenberger telling lawmakers how the
Biden Administration applied pressure to
shut down free speech I regret to inform
the subcommittee today that the scope
power and lawbreaking of the censorship
industrial complex are even worse than
we had realized we both talked about how
this isn't a partisan issue at all uh
despite the fact that it's been
repeatedly described as a right-wing
conspiracy we found evidence of
suppression of movements on both
sides but the Democrats were not
concerned about government pushing
censorship the First Amendment say The
Government Can
censor they're not censoring they're
flagging in the social media
compan 35% of a First Amendment or it's
not the first amendment it's the terms
of service as you said and they are
flagging it for the social media
companies to make their own decisions
that is not the first amendment that is
the terms of service wow but Congressman
Dan Goldman was not done there he now
claims the hunter Biden laptop isn't
real you have no idea you know hard
drive a conspirac are you suggesting the
New York Post participating in a
conspiracy to construct the contents of
the hunterbiden laptop no sir the
problem is that hard drives can be
manipulated by Rudy Giuliani or Russia
what's the evidence that that happened
well there is actual evidence of it but
the point is it's not
so you're engaging in a
conspiracy uh Jesse are you concerned
about what you just heard there I am big
brother used to just want to listen to
us and now they want to tape our mouth
shut well actually 35% of our mouths
could you imagine this was like a speech
tax because that's what it feels like
you know I get to
say 65% of what I think but the
government gets to take the rest no no
no no no no and I'm not saying the
government is into tyranny but I think
they're comfortable with it because
they've already censored they've already
gagged they've already arrested Donald
Trump they're trying to replace me with
a robot they're trying to boycott and
bankrupt our companies so at a certain
point it makes me think they're not into
democracy because the best part about
democracy is we're giving these
politicians power to represent us we're
not giving them power over us they work
for us we have power over them and the
Supreme Court made it clear the
Constitutions made it clear you can't
abridge Free Speech yet the Democrats
are out on live television saying yeah
let's go this is crazy they're calling
it disinformation but it's actually just
a conversation we're all having and we
used to have a great conversation you
remember in the colonial times you used
to just have these publishing houses
that would print the ridicule against
the church or slavery or the king and it
would have this great conversation in
the country and then we had television
and then they had these TV licens three
media corporations and now we just have
the internet so the government can just
go through the back door of the internet
and hit kill switches no that's why I'm
GNA start street preaching wow okay well
we look forward to that judge are you of
a leap are you concerned that this is
happening more and more and to Matt H's
point on both
sides the what these people are saying
is that the government has the ability
to skew Americans views based upon their
own politics and what taibi and
shellenberg are talking about is in 2019
and 2020 during the presidential
election we saw it happen we saw the
heads of the FBI and and um um there our
intelligence communities say you know
that the laptop was Russian
disinformation but it what what was most
concerning was that they said it was not
just in the United States with the FBI
the CIA and homelands security that it
was with the UK as well and if you think
back in 2016 who did Hillary Clinton go
to to get Russian disinformation on
Donald Trump she went to Christopher
steel who was a spy in the in the UK so
it's not just in the United States it's
it's with our so-called Partners uh in
Great Britain but this guy Dan Goldman
is dangerous because he thinks that
taking away 35% of free speech is okay
because he he is couching it as in terms
of uh uh uh of the of the company which
is nonsense it's BS and he's saying that
that laptop is really you know that hard
drive may not be uh legitimate that it
may have been manipulated because it
might have been manipulated well there
might be martians up there watching us
right now but because it may be doesn't
mean that it is and unless you show
actual manipulation you cannot try to
con the American public into thinking
that that hard drive is not the real
hard drive especially when Hunter Biden
admitted it was his and denying the
laptop Harold did that did that surprise
you by representative of Congress um so
I it did a little bit um I love
exchanges like this uh with before
congressional committees oversight
committees because I think when you get
two smart people with uh fact-based
arguments going back and forth they they
they they were yelling it got a little
noisy but it was it was informative
noisy it was substantive noisy uh and I
think that shellenberg at least what I
saw the exchanges got the better of of
Congressman Goldman in the exchange at
least on the on the substance of of what
they were debating every 15 20 years
used to be every 30 40 years we'd go
through these kind of episodes in our
country where we would really probe and
want to understand examine how
government might be pressuring
individuals or institutions to say
certain things or not say certain things
we saw it during the Civil Rights era
where people were uh e dropped on
because we thought they might have been
threats to the country as they were
fighting vigorously for people's
freedoms uh and that this that balance
that recalibration always comes every
every every 10 15 20 years in this in
this instance we're going to get a big
one we'll get a big one next year uh as
the court takes up the Missouri V Biden
case which will determine what are the
limits uh The Government Can can exert
on companies or individuals and asking
them to regulate or uh uh for that
matter tame or expand their speech if
these allegations are right that the
government and it seems that some of
them are SRA that that the government
was in the business of trying to tell
them what to do or trying to tell them
what information was okay what what
information is permissible that's wrong
and I'm I'm glad this hearing is taking
place and again these are the kind of
oversight efforts that I think the
American people deserve whether you
agree with what happened or you disagree
with what happened we all should agree
with the fact that no one's right to
speak whether I agree with you or
disagree with you should be infringed
upon because I don't like what you're
saying I'm a little disappointed that
I'm going last because I would have
loved to hear Harold's rebuttal I'm
afraid we won't have time to hear
response I'm going respond okay good uh
I appreciate how you say that over time
the Embrace of free speech might have
swung ideologically there might have
been a time in this country when the
right was the one pushing I wasn't
saying it that way I'm just saying it
just swings well you talk about the
equilibrium here's what I think is is
undebatable right now the regime of
censorship in this country in the
current modern moment of America is
being driven wholeheartedly by the left
openly and in this hearing Democrats are
now the party of censorship maybe one
day that will not be the case but that
is certainly the case today we also have
the not the news the bid
administration's pressuring YouTube to
take people anyone that has any
hesitancy about the vaccine when demand
did not meet Supply to take it down then
this is in 2021 so and by the way the
left as an ideology generally doesn't
Embrace free speeches to the same level
as the right globally look at the UK
look at look at Europe Canada hate
speech laws generally there's this idea
I'm offended by what you have to say
therefore I should be able to shut you
up the only defense for this country
which which is the Hallmark of free
speech in this world right now is the
American right I'm not here to tell you
that I trust the American right for Here
to Eternity it's not that they have a
sterling record on this but as a as an
absolute proponent of free speech I do
know this if you have faith if you need
this part of the American experiment to
last you need the American right to
believe this I will watch them like a
hawk but the left Herold is lost they're
gone they believe in censorship not the
first amendment and so said the court so
said the court and that's on its way to
the Supreme Court that is a circuit
court of appeals has ruled that that is
the case no one has a monopoly on
stupidity or trying to encroach on
people this point they do and and at
this moment there's no doubt the left
needs to be it needs to be calibrated
but I would remind you that just a year
ago we were had a speech conversation
about whether people should be able to
teach certain things in class and people
said no I don't want that people thought
that were their free speech rights were
being infringed upon all I'm saying is
let's let it all out there and let's
have this debate and this debate that
happened before Congress you're right
what the left is none of what some are
doing is wrong and it should be
corrected I don't care if it's the right
or the left instigating it it should be
correct I appreciate that and you watch
the right through I I I believe in free
speech even the speech that I hate I'm
terrified for the future of the First
Amendment and I'm for the Rangers got
it's easy to jump on the bandwagon now
it at that hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
El